see it's very
uh deceivingly simple
okay so give him the opening
all right now the problem is
i have this cut that's coming straight
okay you're gonna want to move over here
and then off
we're not doing that
i'm going to turn on this foot
turn on this one and that's going to
make me get off the line
and what i'm looking for is to be
inside his weapon the in space behind
his cut
it allows me to catch his weapon almost
without coming here
my body curves my weapon can be up and
down
and yet act like it's a curvy weapon
okay
okay okay what you're going to notice
is that as he comes in here
i don't leave right away
my strategy is different
okay so boom i kind of have to wait
i'll show you i won't i won't wait i
move with him the angles
crisscross do you see if i put the angle
where i was
i would miss so shiro tencon
is going to use not
a creating of distance but a rotational
deviation that's going to require that
i'm waiting here much
longer than you might want to so i'll do
it both ways deviating ahead of him you
can see my angle is off
and waiting longer wait then i'll catch
it
distance off it's off angle weird
waiting deviating me second one
i'll reach out to make contact if i'm
going to catch his weapon
i have to first reach for his weapon
and then absorb his weapon okay so if i
was going to catch this
the ball or something my hands are out
and
i will absorb the ball in my hands don't
stay here and i let it hit me
my hands don't stay there and i let it
hit my hands so i will reach
for i reach for it and then absorb that
coming back here
reach for it don't absorb it coming back
boom waiting
waiting absorb catch
up okay so we're gonna work with yokoma
now
i'm gonna take those those last two
things so
he's coming up and i am going to
seek contact initially
but i'm not going to do is he goes and
then i do this
so i see contact initially i stay
on that single pivot point in this case
the right knee
without moving back
so this is going to be incorrect
and this is going to be incorrect
immediately seek the relationship and
then yield to it
seek it feel to it
here we go
focusing on the strife okay so
i contact i'll feel i'll feel the
pressure
so i'm going inside and what i'm gonna
do is drop my elbow
i'm not going to take my hand down
my elbow is going to drop boom right
there
up and my elbow is gonna drop
boom right here
[Music]
people are punch out here they're
they're not in tight when they're
punching
the joe's key same thing they're hitting
hitting from out here was supposed to
hit him there
kicking is always out of range and the
same thing with yoko ben
yoko if people want to go like this
he just punched you in the face when you
come around thank you
okay uh also that's not biomechanically
sound
my majority of my mass is far from my
weapon and that's the target the elbow
joint
is you got a joint in the middle of the
lever that's a weak point too so there's
going to be energy leakage there and
probably an injury so my hand will come
up
up the center line and i'm going to use
my body
to change whatever angle that i might
need but i don't make my hand go to the
side
so my hand comes up and then my elbow
drops
in and then my body my body
my whole body is hitting
10 card okay so this part's all the same
i'll come up i see
contact all right i'm going to shift
weight onto
a single pivot point and i'm going to
rotate
and so i'll be inside of that strike
and then this isn't anything this is
just me getting a new vector of attack
okay so uh i'll shift onto the single
pivot point so there's no no weight on
this foot
and i will rotate out of the way
boom single pivot boom
reach out for contact single pivots out
of the way same thing my elbow will drop
inside bubble mission strength
contact boom elbow drops inside
boom elbow
long elbows
okay now that the checking hand is
getting you okay so he's going this hand
right here is getting
you going like this okay we'll do this
side
um and you're painting the picture
you're like i'm making him go
down i'm not making himself
just like in the sword i'm not knocking
him down
i just am adhering to the movement
so as we're going up i'm adhering to the
movement
it's gonna do me different different
things okay
the first thing is i actually have a
check if i'm on the inside and i want to
stay on the inside of his hand
i don't want to go on the outside of his
hand
so i have to stay perpendicular to my
angle of cancellation
not go over it he can hug me and all
kinds of stuff
keep him on the outside if i'm on the
inside so i'm on the inside
i'm on the inside
so then when i'm on the inside like this
instead of
tilting him i just let his strike keep
going into the
technique when you tilt him you're
trying to change the direction of the
strike
well his strike's coming here boom
now i'm just staying inside of that
okay next thing is when i if i use i
like the adhesion rather than an
external check
just just kind of hang and just kind of
hang out uh
you can affect his balance more
much more than you go and you're just
trying to cut this down
okay so instead i'm i'm blending with
this energy and i just keep
extending that into the stripe into his
strike
he will send in the indigestion
so standing the that hands there this
time this is coming in
boom
boom so i'll keep doing it but you're
watching the checking hats
okay so let's again look at the checking
hand
okay so he's going up i reach out to get
him now he's going to drop his elbow
inside
it's going to be inward pressure right
there we're going to go really slow
okay so as i feel his inner pressure
that's when i start
yielding on this foot do you see that's
going to
stop that's go back that's going to
decide
uh that oh i'm going to a shield tank on
okay
so i'm over here and at a certain
point as i rotate into this i can't go
anymore and i feel
that pressure now on me so that's when i
go ahead and step back so you're still
doing the yielding strategy
okay so i'm going up his pressure is
coming
in so i will shift weight that's me
moving in the same direction you don't
have to
tilt your head i'm still moving in the
same direction
as his weapon is i'm going to rotate and
now
here i can't go i can't turn anymore and
that's when my foot will move and yield
again
okay so again up that's the first yield
i'm done rotating and that is exactly
where the
sheet of tank happens
long shift rotate
then i can't rotate anymore i can't
rotate anymore
so that's he's now still pushing on me
and that's where the
tank on happens okay but
watch how i'm using my inward and hours
spirals
my hand is not straight
out trying to do this thing
all of the yielding is happening also
with my spirals so
i'm going to show you he's going to come
in and when i feel the pressure
you see how as i rotate
i can take that pressure off so i'm not
here
and just moving out of the way
my arm itself is going through its own
yin phases
as it's going through the inward spiral
womb
i feel you'll feel that pressure turn
inside of it so
boom turn
not one two i had no awareness of that
or worse boom
come up and rotate inside of it
boom you see you can do this here past
that same
um i passed the contention point
so pay attention how this hand is
rotating palm
towards me then out
even if i start here i'm cognizant that
i can rotate this hand
it's almost the opposite because you
want to go this way
and i'm actually going this way
the other side my hands going this
inside from this thing this way
use your spirals
the more your spirals are yielding boom
then the more less deviation you
actually need
the less time you need is this a
redundant system
you guys see how much is taking off
okay